this video will explain the story of God
of War Ragnarok the plan is to talk
about both the main story and ending as
well as any mythology that we happen to
run across I read Neil gaiman's version
of Norse mythology in order to
understand some of Ragnarok but I do
know that it's not 100 accurate to the
original text but it does seem to at
least keep the general idea intact as
always spoiler warning ahead as this
covers the whole story of Ragnarok but
I'll also be referencing some of the
events from God of War 2018 and some of
the Greek games as well to provide some
context I want to keep this intro as
short as possible but before we start I
want to let you know that I have dozens
of other story explanation videos like
this on other games but if you're
looking for more opinionated pieces I
have lots of story reviews on a plethora
of games and series including all the
God of War games in one video so if that
sounds entertaining to you then feel
free to stick around after you watch
this video with that out of the way
though let's get started
so God of War Ragnarok takes place three
years after God of War 2018.
thimblewinter the three year long winter
that started after we killed balder back
in the last game is now in full effect
but it's foretold that Ragnarok shortly
follows after its three-year Reign
Kratos has gotten older and so has
atreus atreus seems to be able to hold
his own now as he has just returned from
hunting and critters is also showing
more wrinkles which conveys his age and
possibly that he's getting weaker over
time the two then set off home before
being interrupted by Freya who's come
for her revenge they managed to get by
unscathed as they make it inside the
protection Stave this spell might
operate a bit differently from phase
protection spell FaZe was used to hide
their presence and the same might be
true here but it also seems to prevent
people from entering entirely I find it
hard to believe that Freya doesn't know
where they live since they've been here
for over three years so maybe it's
stopping her from entering when the two
fight a few Raiders later atreus
mentions how they must have snuck in
while The Stave was down so it seems to
operate like a shield that no one but
them can enter Freya also attacks them
which is odd as she was cursed out to
harm anything but we learned that when
fimbo went to arrive the curse is on her
weekend a bit once Kratos and atreus
make it home we see more of the new
family that being three wolves Specky
Savannah and fenrir Specky and svana are
two wolves that pull the sled and were
found one day when they were out hunting
the two then rescued the wolves from a
group of Raiders and they've been with
them ever since according to the Codex
fenrir was already on the decline when
they met them this of course leads to
today when atreya says his final
goodbye's defenry before he passes
fenway's soul is then seen leaving his
body before going into the sky we
learned eventually that atreus has a
knife that can carry a soul in it which
will then be used later once the two
meet garm afterward we get into this
entry's game-long argument whereas in
2018 atreus and Kratos argued over
atreus's skill and attitude it's now
about atreus wanting to learn about Loki
and how the two have a lack of trust
Kratos wants to protect atreus and make
sure he is safe while Trace wants to
explore the Realms and figure out who
Loki is and what he should be doing
these ideals conflict which is why Trey
sneaks out all the time Kratos then goes
inside to talks with Amir who is still
with the group and then goes to bed
Curtis will experience quite a few
dreams like this throughout the game all
of which revolve around Faye who finally
shows her face for the first time in the
series The Dream is fine for a time
until Fey seems to change character a
bit and tells Kratos that time is
running out craters can't seem to catch
a break as right after this he sets off
to find atreus as he was supposed to
bury fenru but hasn't returned Kratos
then finds a bear which he almost kills
before discovering that it is atreus
Loki in the mythology is a shape-shifter
as he took the appearance of a salmon
bird and a horse at one point atreus at
least within the bounds of the game
seems to only be able to transform into
a bear and then later a wolf I can't
imagine though that with time he will be
able to transform into more animals once
the two return home a one-to-one
recreation of the last game's ending is
shown which means Thor is here to play
despite what the last game made us think
he's not actually here to fight but
rather talk as he enters two Ravens
enter with him which means Odin is
watching and sure enough he arrives
shortly after these birds are hungan and
moonin they're a little bit different
from the Ravens we've seen around the
game as they're not only stored on his
arm in the form of tattoos but they
specifically according to the myth go
around the Realms providing Odin with
information Odin sits down with the
group and talks about the past events
Odin is not upset at the fact that
Kratos kill magni and Modi but he is
upset that he killed balder Odin calls
the brothers useless which bothers Thor
Thor is shown to be quite the broken man
in this game he like atreus as a father
with impossibly high expectations that
he will never reach a tracing Kratos
inevitably recognize this and talk about
it but Odin doesn't he always tells Thor
how he's a much better person when he
doesn't think Thor is very upset that
his sons have died but doesn't say
anything as it will anger Odin Odin came
here to the home to broke her piece
because Odin just wants to find answers
which we'll talk about in a moment but
also because atreus keeps searching for
tear something Kratos was unaware of
Odin offers peace and while that would
be something Kratos would want as he
wants to stop fighting and protect
atreus the man who asked for peace is
not to be trusted so he declines this
then leads to the fight between Thor and
Kratos according to the dialogue during
the fight it seems that siegren being
rescued was Canon and that the story of
the ghost of Sparta is indeed a
widespread tale that the gods of these
Realms are familiar with during the
fight Thor and Kratos enter a stalemate
that ends up with Kratos getting killed
but then gets revived shortly after as
Thor uses mill near as a defibrillator
this seems to be an intended game
mechanic but only a one-time use as I
died after this and Thor didn't revive
me again this also technically means
that Thor is now the third member of the
I killed Kratos Club just behind Ares
and Zeus Kratos then rages and socks
Thor in the face which according to him
was a sufficient enough blood payment
for his son's death so he leaves Brock
and Century come by after the fight and
take Kratos back home while Kratos and
Thor were fighting Odin was talking with
atreus and asked if he wanted to come to
Asgard with him we also learned that
Odin doesn't really care much about
yotenheim anymore as he's focused on
something else as we briefly mentioned
atreus was searching for tear this goes
back to him wanting to find out more
about Loki the Giants and Ragnarok while
searching for answers he visited those
old yotnaar shrines from the previous
game and found out that they have a
secret room behind the panels each one
has a more detailed and truthful story
of the beings on the panels inside we
see the story of skull and hottie from
the previous game we learned that skull
and hati chased the moon in sun which is
why the world has a day night cycle Odin
captured them because it's prophesized
that once the Wolves devour their target
Ragnarok will begin that's what the
panel says but inside the shrine it
shows the Giants taking the Wolves back
and releasing them the wolves are now in
vanaheim safe from Odin but eventually
the moon will get stolen someone then
comes by puts the moon back and shoots
an arrow into the sky returning the
Wolves back to how they were this of
course is exactly what happens later in
the game when we go to vanheim this
leads to the final part which shows tear
leading the armies of the Realms against
Odin to atreus this means that tear is
alive and is just locked up somewhere
after discussing it a bit they
determined that he might be in
svalterheim home of the dwarves to get
there though they need to visit syndra
who lives in the realm between Realms
inside here is also ratatosker the
messenger of the world tree we also
learned why he's so different in God of
War 2018. one of the trace's spectral
summons was a talking squirrel which was
one of ratatosker's spectral aspects
called bitter on the way to tear the two
meet durlan who was a part of a
rebellion that Faye had led she along
with the dwarves went against Asgard
since Odin used them quite often to
produce various devices for him but
according to Durland the Rebellion
failed after a long walk the two fine
tear the Norse god of war but as we know
that is not tear but rather Odin posing
as tear we can find the real tier later
after the game is over and that
conversation confirms that tear wasn't
switched out at some point but was never
there to begin with this was Odin from
the very start the biggest question
though is how is this possible how can
he be Odin and tear honestly I'm not
really sure how he pulled this off but
he does have the Raven so he likely
teleported back to Asgard when no one
was looking this is a little odd though
because atreus goes to Asgard and is
gone for quite a long time yet no one
questions what tier was doing during
that time this may have been intentional
though because tear is not a very
important character in this game he just
kind of exists and will acknowledge this
one at the table this would be helpful
for Odin since tear would be so useless
to the team that if he happened to leave
no one would notice Kratos in the gang
then returned to Century's home and rest
atreus doesn't want to waste any time so
he ends up sneaking out at night and for
the first time in the whole franchise we
finally take control of someone other
than Kratos address wants to learn more
about Loki so he wants to go visit Freya
syndrie is very concerned about this
idea so we suggest that he visit your
banganger instead German Gander isn't
very helpful since all he says is
Ironwood and Freya isn't much help
either since she might have a grudge
against him Freya is also the reason why
the Raiders attempted to kill Kratos
earlier in the game because she told
them that if they kill the Kratos the
snow would be gone which of course is a
lie but they bought it anyway atreus
then tells her about how they broke out
tear and open access to all the other
Realms but Freya doesn't want to hear
anymore and tells a trace to leave this
is because of what happens later when
Freya comes by and works with Kratos to
break the curse she realizes that she
might finally be able to leave midgard
for once so she needed time to think it
over and plan the only other detail we
learned on this trip is about rock and
syndra and that's that a long time ago
Brock was killed in an accident when
working on the forge syndrin went to
helheim to get his soul Parts back but
only could retrieve three of the four
parts meaning he's not a full person now
that the Realms are open the group
decides that alphaim is the next step as
grow a shrine is located there groa was
the one who force all the event of
Ragnarok in the first place so it's
possible that the Secret Story inside
the shrine might provide more
information on the finer details once we
enter Alpha and we see that things are
different storms have ruined the desert
and thimble winter isn't making that any
better as we know from God of War 2018
the dark elves fought the light elves
and we helped the light elves drive them
back but we know that there hasn't been
a true Victor as War happens constantly
back before the conflict there was just
elves there was even a statue of one in
the temple once the light of alphaim was
discovered though there was a division
amongst them when the nine Realms were
first created the dead started Gathering
down here in the lake of souls they then
built the temple of Alzheimer on the
lights in an attempt to harness its
energy those who became addicted to its
power started to worship it which is how
the light elves came to be the light of
alphaim though ruined the precious
desert just outside the temple because
of the elf's insistence on capturing its
power the dark elves of action was then
created because of this because they
believed that the natural resources need
to stay natural and must not be
disturbed this then led to their long
conflict until freyr came by freyr
brother of Freya visited alphaim was
able to unite the elves and prevent from
fighting he then ended up leaving
alphaim though because of the marriage
between Odin and Freya he returned to
vanaheim in order to protest against
their marriage but once he left the
conflict between the elves was reignited
inside grow a shrine we see her full
story grower lost her husband at one
point and attempted to find him she
meditated to find him but she ended up
finding a vision of the end of the world
this news of course reached Odin so he
set out to find her he was clearly
displeased by the information because he
killed her shortly after we then see
more Ragnarok stuff but we learned that
it's on a world-ending event it actually
just destroys Asgard and the other
Realms thrive in its absence with that
knowledge in mind the group heads back
home again because they need to plan
there is quite a bit of talk about what
atreya should do in this game and Kratos
doesn't want to hear any of it you'll be
able to recognize who's on whose side
for the most part based on what they
call him treya says that he's not Loki
but atreus he sees him as his son not
some prophesies being others see him as
Loki like anger Boda who atres will meet
once he goes to bed we discover though
that this isn't some dream like with
Faye and Kratos this is actually
happening he was able to travel here by
sleeping anger Boda is a giant who lives
here in Ironwood the secret Sanctuary
anger Boda lives here alone since all
the Giants are dead or so it seems
according to anger Boda her Destiny is
to show atreus his Destiny this means
that he'll have to read The Stonewall
from the last game and now knows that
Kratos will die so now it's not about
starting Ragnarok about preventing it
because he doesn't want Kratos to die
since Kratos is also aware of this
prophecy the two of them know what will
happen but are unaware that the other
knows it yet anger Boda also shows the
trays where the Giants went they didn't
actually die but rather hid themselves
in these small marbles she assumes that
she has all of them but since atreus
found some in midgard when visiting the
shrines she realizes this isn't the full
set and that there are more out there
the Giants had the option of either
waiting for Odin to find a way inside
yotenheim which would eventually lead to
their Slaughter or play dead and hide
they of course opted to play dead and
hide atreus now has them and according
to her will know what to do when the
time is right this likely means
releasing them back into the world once
Odin is dead one of the marbles in the
bag though is FaZe marble but it's empty
so she can't be revived she however
gives it to atreus which we can assume
would be used on Kratos so that he can
save him from his fated death and
garbota though becomes a bit angry after
this talk since according to atreus's
panel she disappears after this
conversation so she'll likely die or
fizzle out of his story since she served
her purpose atreus though won't let that
happen and asks for her to take the
marbles and for her to find the other
Giants which she of course agrees to the
two of them really start to hit it off
quite a bit and this relates back to the
mythology as Loki in agner Boda are
actually husband and wife and their
children are jormungander fenrir and
hell but since Loki doesn't exist in God
of War at least not in the traditional
sense their origin was Rewritten fenrir
was just the size of a wolf but in the
myth he's actually quite large
furthermore dormingander makes an
appearance as the snake they rescued
together ends up growing at an alarming
rate towards the finale so like the
previous game Santa Monica is changing
the Mythology by altering the story but
keeping most of the end results the same
balder dies from a mistletoe Arrow but
not from it being thrown at him but by
balther punching it atreus didn't marry
agner Boda nor did they create their
children but they do exist in the
chemistry between the two is very
apparent as well atreus will then say
goodbye to agner Boda and wake up at his
old home in midgard Kratos arrives and
the two argue that they're interrupted
by a valkyrie who they learn is actually
just Freya Kratos has to control atres
from biting freyja because his emotions
overtook him again just like before
Freya once again contemplates what to do
as Kratos still considers her a friend
but they also kill their son she spares
them again because Kratos is more used
to her alive she wants Curtis to go to
Anaheim with her because that is where
her curse that keeps her held in midgard
is being hidden she then assumes the
appearance of a bird which is a neat way
around the curse as it was designed to
trap Freya not a bird the reason she
couldn't do this herself was that her
abilities are limited as a bird and
because she also needed help breaking
the other weaker curses this help was
likely sigrun as Freya says that she
came to her Aid once we freed her last
game here in vanheim is a ragtag group
of people a dwarf a dark elf a light elf
and a traveler led by frere freyr is
trying to defend Anaheim from Odin and
his forces but seeing as there's only
five of them they're not really doing
too well while mimir and frere discuss
the battle plan Freya and Kratos set out
in search of the curse during this
journey Kratos and Freya will talk about
their relationship girders will then
tell her about the story of his brother
Deimos in his tragic backstory this of
course being the time when the God of
War Aries tricked him into killing his
own wife and daughter this is rather
interesting because he has yet to tell
atreus about these details vitreus is
unaware their creatives had another wife
and child back at Greece and that he
killed him which of course has me
wondering if that will ever come up
again as for Deimos he wasn't mentioned
much in the series except for one game
where he was the main focal point Ghost
of Sparta in that story it's learned
that Athena and ares went to Sparta to
find a marked Warrior because it was
foretold that a marked Warrior would
bring down Olympus they assumed it was
Deimos because of his notable scar but
we all know that was the wrong choice
Kratos manages to find demos but he is
initially angry at him since Kratos
never rescued him Kratos tells this
story to fray because of her conflicted
relationship with her brother freyr
freyr and Freya got into a fight during
the wedding Freya had with Odin this was
the last time the two spoke so they left
off on a bad note to be fair though
freyr had every right to hold grudge
against Odin Odin's and Acer and the
only reason they ever got married was to
stop the war between the Acer and vanir
but more importantly freyr was burned by
the Acer after the marriage the Vanier
taught the Acer some of their magic but
because they were brutal and
non-disciplined people they often blame
their teachers when things went wrong
freyr taught some of the Acer how to
improve their crop yields but when the
magic didn't work they burned him for it
eventually Kratos and Freya will then
make it to the source of the curse and
have to fight need hog to break it
needog protects the Yeager still roots
from harm so it's not that nidhog wants
to fight us because we're trying to
break the curse but because we're trying
to break the roots of the world tree
which holds the curse once Freya breaks
the curse she is able to travel in her
human form but that also means Kratos is
no longer needed however thanks to their
long talk she realizes that Kratos isn't
the enemy it's Odin this means that the
two are friends again and also means
that Kratos has another Ally willing to
help him we can also help Fran a future
favor Quest by going to the marriage
Temple and getting rid of all the stuff
that still has ties to Asgard it's
during this time though that she
realizes that she'll never be able to
distance herself from Asgard because of
balder and the Valkyries she recognizes
though that it's not just Odin's realm
but hers too she was the queen after all
this side quest lets her feel at peace
with everything that's happened in her
life which is a touching end to the
quest now that the task has been
completed Freire and Freya can meet and
since Freya is willing to help us you
can also get a chance to catch up with
fake tear as well this may also be hint
at the reveal as tear calls her frigg
some of the Gods in Norse mythology have
different names denoting different
things Freya is a name that represents
the Vanier goddess and frig is a name
that represents the wife of Odin they're
the same person just two different names
Odin would of course call her frig but
it's subtle enough to not draw any
attention because tear was an Acer so it
wouldn't be out of the ordinary for him
to call her afraid as well once everyone
makes it back to cindery's house Kratos
talks to trace about where he went he
can't reveal anything since he promised
agner Boda that he wouldn't tell anyone
about Ironwood this then leads to
another argument where everyone is
questioning if he went to Asgard to meet
Odin he clearly didn't but ends up going
anyway as his emotions overcome him
again and he storms out of the house but
not before injuring sindri a tourist
then arrives in midgarden makes a way to
free his old home when inside a raven
will enter which means that Odin is
watching he then talks the Raven and
asks it to take him to Asgard the bird
accepts and throws him just outside the
wall just in case you're confused about
this decision atres wants to go here
because he wants to work with and
against Odin he wants to prevent
Ragnarok because it'll kill Kratos but
he can't do that cooped up in the house
all day plus Kratos won't let him leave
so he has to do this alone against his
wishes that's why he goes to Asgard with
the hope that by working with Odin he
can find answers about Loki and stop
Ragnarok thankfully Odom wants the same
thing he doesn't care about Ragnarok as
he only cares about this Terror
according to Odin this tear holds
knowledge and truth it will allow him to
change his fate Revenge Ragnarok and
save people the problem though is that
he can't look into it because when he
did he lost his eye mamir in the last
game explains it when he first met Odin
he told him that he could see Visions in
this well it was really just a regular
well filled with magical mushrooms but
apparently he did see something in it
whether or not it was real due to the
mushrooms is unclear but it was enough
for Odin to dedicate his whole life to
it he's been trying to open it and
understand it for lifetimes but hasn't
gotten anywhere atress though is able to
help him so he can translate what is
written on the mask so the two work
together to uncover its Secrets the
underlying issue though is that it's
Odin Odin when talking with atreus Will
say that mortals can look to the gods
for answers they can also go to Valhalla
or vanheim when they die their lives
continue after death but that's for
Mortals what about gods they can't look
to hire beings for answers because they
are the higher beings and because
they're different they don't know what
will happen when they die back in 2018
when we killed magni and Modi a trace
question why the Valkyries didn't come
pick them up yet the afterlife for Gods
may be different or even non-existent
while all of us here have our opinions
on the afterlife we don't have
definitive proof nobody has actually
been to heaven in return so we can't say
for certain that's why some believe in
Gods and others don't the same question
about what happens after death is the
one Odin is asking but he might actually
have the answer if he looks through the
terror it's a normal dream and ambition
to have and almost makes you look at
Odin differently but we also have to
remember he's a pathological liar and
manipulator so preventing Ragnarok could
just mean killing everyone that is and
Acer and changing his fate might just
mean never being killed since he'll
always know how he dies it's hard to
understand what his true intentions are
he could be genuine but he could not be
on her way to meet Odin a trace will
come across Thor his family and Heimdall
Heimdall is the Watcher of the Gods and
has the power to know people's
intentions which is why he can't be hit
he knows what you will do and can react
accordingly it's not that he can see
into the future like the Giants he can
only see their intentions so if someone
is angry and plans to swing at him he'll
notice ahead of time and Dodge it
Heimdall is also the owner of the
gallerhorn despite what you may think it
is not actually an exotic rocket
launcher but just a real horn this is
the horn that starts the Battle of
Ragnarok and he is the keeper of it as
for Thor's family we have thrued and Sif
thrude is the daughter of Thor and a
sister to magni and Modi Sif is their
mother and Thor's wife but sadly not
much is known about her her main claim
to fame is her long golden hair but
that's about it sifin through get into
arguments quite a bit because dude wants
to become a valkyrie but Sif forbids her
from doing so it's learned later that
sieve did indeed want her to be a
valkyrie after all just not under Odin's
rule since Odin is a very harsh ruler
oddly enough in the myth through does
exist but there's also a valkyrie with
the same name as her that serves ale to
the Warriors of Valhalla but it's always
been unclear whether or not they're the
same person or just have the same name
so who knows maybe her dream will come
true after all a trace at one point will
walk with Odin and we can see the world
through his eyes we see three Valkyries
Christ and Mist as well as the new
Valkyrie Queen Gana we also see how much
power Odin has over the dwarf says
falter fine because his requests are
very demanding and he is unwilling to
compromise on them when the two go back
to Odin's room atreus finds a sword that
moves on its own called Ingrid this is
actually a freyr's signature weapon but
he left it here I will Circle back to
this in a bit back to the task at hand
Odo wants a trace to find the other two
mask pieces after translating the first
part they determine it's in moospelheim
so he asked to trace to take Thor with
him atreus then distracts Thor by
telling him he could participate in the
trials of cerder which he did in the
last game Thor of course agrees because
killing is fun to him which allows a
trace to look and assert her Shrine here
in muspelheim he's not the only one
though who wanted to look inside his
agar Boda is here and says that she's
still looking for more marbles sorter is
a fire Giant and it's prophesized that
during Ragnarok sorter is the one that
breaks down the walls of Asgard to do
that though Serta and his wife sin Mara
are supposed to join together and become
Ragnarok once he learns this information
a trace leaves just in time for Thor to
finish killing they then find the mask
and report back to Odin atreus is now
tasked with translating the final piece
but before that happens we are sent back
to Kratos and set off on his journey
which as we discover is to find the
norns the norns are the Norse versions
of the Fates similar to the ones from
Grease their three sisters who know the
fate of the world and its inhabitants
the norns say though that they know what
they will do because they don't change
the norns aren't omniscient beings that
know anything and everything they know
what will happen because of people's
predictable choices balder was destined
to die a needless death and he did Frey
couldn't let her son go and thus made
him Invincible balder couldn't control
his rage and vowed to kill Freya the
next time they met and Kratos is a god
killer all of their predictable choices
led to the death of balder the final
line ERD says really puts it well she
says that they are the sum of their
choices and because their choices never
change Ragnarok will start so to prevent
Ragnarok they must change they then
leave the land of the norns but not
before taking a noose with them which is
the Noose Odin hanged himself with
lifetimes ago he one day decided to hang
himself from the world tree for nine
whole days in his quest to find the
secrets of the world once they return
home they all discuss what to do about
Heimdall as an Owens claim the Heimdall
will kill atreus he has heightened
senses so Brock thinks that overloading
them will work to do that though they
need drop near in the myth brockett's
injury competed against the sons of
Vivaldi to see who could make the better
gift for the gods if all these Sons
created gun gear Odin spear a silk scarf
that transforms into a boat called skid
blog near which we'll see later when we
meet freyr again and long golden hair
for Sith because Loki got drunk one
night and cut it off broken's injury
made mjolnir which won them the contest
Bull and bursti which is a golden board
that drives ferreira's Chariot and drop
near a magical ring that makes eight
other rings every nine days this was a
gift for Odin but syndrie has it here in
his house which means he stole it from
Odom one day they keep the ring down
here though because they would melt down
the Rings they would make and use it for
their projects Brock believes that if
they use this and make a spear he should
be able to kill Heimdall to craft this
weapon though they'll need to go to
smartlime and meet the lady of the forge
the lady is a mermaid and uses the
ingredients as well as kratos's blood to
craft the spear they need to defeat
Heimdall but when Brock has her to bless
it she doesn't respond or at least
doesn't seem to mermaids don't talk
physically they communicate by talking
to a person's soul but since Brock is
missing a fourth of his soul he can't
hear her that's when he learns about the
truth of what happened that day at the
forge before the good leaves fart
they'll find him and go home Odin and
the two talk similar to their previous
talk Odin still wants peace and doesn't
want war but one line that sticks out is
when he talks about what Kratos knows
about godhood he asks if anyone actually
worshiped him and if he even cares about
Mortals honestly it's a fair question
the only people who praise Kratos as a
god were the Spartan warriors as they
prayed for assistance in their battles
but that was it Gratis has never truly
been worshiped as a god before and
everyone in Greece died eventually so it
doesn't even matter anymore Kratos is
now just a god of no Renown after some
time Kratos decides to return home and
caught at night we didn't get another
dream of Faye and Kratos as they take a
trip down the river before Faye tells
him to protect their son we can see a
lot of emotion from Kratos in the scene
and a lot of others as well he's
terrified of losing a trace and at times
is almost on the verge of tears because
of it we then go back to atreus and see
that he through and skojir are talking
School junior is actually from midgard
in the previous game we heard a bit
about something called The Desolation
when that happened Odin took those who
survived and brought them here to Asgard
they aren't inside the wall of Asgard
they're not that special but they do
live right outside the wall which I
guess is close enough atreus then meets
with Odin and tells him that the final
piece is in helheim he's then sent off
to helheim with rude and Heimdall as
company Heimdall is here to retrieve the
moon which is what leads to the future
events in vanheim but before that
happens we need to follow this new Duo
to their destination The Mask points him
to this place and helheim where garm the
hellhound is located atres ends of free
and garm because he cares for animals
and believes that it wants to be free
this is very problematic as garm has the
power to open realm Terrors anywhere he
wants garm arm being loose is a problem
for anyone no matter the location or
realm they reside in a trace is so upset
by this that he decides he wants to go
home and he doesn't want to do this
anymore atres might also be a bit
homesick as it's been a long time since
he's seen his friends surprisingly Odin
is not mad at him he's disappointed
because he screwed up big time but he
knows that a trace is important to his
mission so he Comforts him instead
telling them that he is still welcome in
Asgard if he ever wants to come back a
trace that makes it back to sindri's
home and he and Kratos hug it out after
learning what happened everyone is
rightfully upset except Kratos who's
just happy to see atreus again the two
then battle garm multiple times before
Trace takes the knife and stabs garm
replacing his soul with fenrir which
explains within the God of War series
how fenra got to his gigantic size
before they return home though the two
probably have the most important
conversation in the game Kratos has
started to recognize how much he slipped
back into his old ways he's angry and
distrustful of atreus and he doesn't
want to be atreus assures him though
that without Kratos he would have been
Reckless and stupid the two then
promised that they will listen to each
other's voices in their heads whenever
they're gone crit just finally comes to
accept the trace's Curiosity and
apologizes for his behavior they then
return to the house again and Kratos
decides not to kill Heimdall he wants to
be better not just for himself but for
atreus and killing Heimdall would go
against that Freya takes off though
because vanheim is under attack by
Odin's forces so she's going to help
them once the two eventually make it
there they'll be ambushed by an Archer
named hildesvini who you'll recognize as
the boratra shot in the last game he was
exiled to midgard in his bore form but
it seems that now he's able to return to
his human form now Kratos in a trace
then do exactly as the skull on hakti
Shrine prophesies by getting the moon
back and shooting an arrow into the sky
so the war can go back to normal the
group then realized that fear has been
captured so they devise a plan but is
interrupted once Heimdall arrives
despite the fact that an hour ago he
said he wouldn't kill him Kratos does it
anyway this is not only problematic for
Kratos because he's going against what
he said but also because Asgard will
hear about this soon and the truth they
had will now be over Kratos didn't
exactly accept the truce in the first
place but Odin honored it anyway now
that's over
creators and Company rescue frere before
using his boat and take it to the sky
the group ends up being attacked and
bierger has to sacrifice himself in
order to save them he's not actually
dead though as you could find him later
in a side quest but it is still a pretty
cool moment since freyr is injured Freya
has to take him to where herbs are in
order to heal him so it's back to the
house again atreya steps up this time
and asks if he can go back to Asgard his
plan is to complete the mask and then
somehow get out before Onika get it back
after some time they agree but are of
course very worried news of heimdall's
death has reached Asgard but atreus is
fine for now he reports back to Odin and
tells him that he mistranslated the mask
and that it's actually a neifleheim this
is a bit strange since the mask only
glows in the direction of the other Mask
Part so how is it glowing in helheim if
it wasn't there to begin with personally
I'm not too sure how that's possible but
regardless Odin suggests that Reyes take
Thor but Thor is currently drinking the
pain away in can't really operate this
leads to an incredible bar fight which
seems to sober him up a bit Thor and a
trace then find the mask but Sif arrives
with the two Valkyries as they have
proof that Kratos killed Heimdall Odin
tells sort of stand down but sif's talks
Thor into fighting as she reminds him
that a trace and cradles are to blame
for the death of their sons thankfully
atres is able to escape before things
get too crazy thanks to a stone Century
gave him before he left I think you know
where atreus ends up going next and once
he gets there the group talks about
their next step since the last problem I
have left is you know actually getting
to Asgard tier claims to know a way but
his question as to why he withheld that
information which leads to the reveal of
Odin and the death of Brock Brock passes
away Odin escapes and syndrie leaves
with Brock's body this then starts
Ragnarok they all realize that war needs
to happen and they can't just avoid it
Freya goes to recruit the elves Freya
goes to visit the Valkyries hildesvini
and mimir go to recruit the Legion of
helheim and Kratos and atreus go to find
sertors that he can destroy the wall
certain though does not want to partake
in the action though because it would
mean the death of his wife what Ops the
sacrifice just himself through a
loophole that he just discovered instead
of combining as the prophecy says he
just uses kratos's blades to heat
samara's heart that's in his chest which
should work fortunately for them it does
but the two have to defeat Hurst and
Miss down here at the spark of the world
once they finish the job they go to
tears Temple and set up a camp as they
prepare for war Kratos gets one last
stream with Faye and tells atreus a
story the story is about a man who would
carry wood for the village he started
getting weaker over time though and he
called for death to come to him to me
this story is supposed to be about
Kratos since in a few hours from now
he's prophesized to die and has accepted
that fate he's fought dozens of gods and
hasn't felt complete peace for years
it's always been about fighting or
hiding he's also still reminded of his
misdeed because the ashes are still on
his skin I don't think those bad
memories are as potent as they were back
in Greece but it's still there
nonetheless Kratos will live of course
which is why the story gets retold again
and is discovered that the man realized
that he wanted to keep living so he
decided to continue carrying wood for
the village Kratos wants to live and be
there for his son he even said earlier
in the game that death can have him when
it earns it clearly it hasn't as for the
dream it takes place around the time him
and Faye were out setting up the trees
and her markings and also when she tells
him how she wants to be burned and have
her ashes spread atop the highest peak
in all the Realms Kratos then wakes up
gathers the group and blows the horn
signaling the start of Ragnarok as they
enter through the portal they see all
the destruction that has already started
Norman Gander fenrir and anger Bodo will
also join the battle a bit later this
yorman Gander though is not the old one
but rather the new one that atreus found
back in yotenheim we'll also see Thor
attack him which is how he gets sent
back in time and then meets the group
again back in 2018. in order for cerder
now Ragnarok to actually destroy the
wall the group needs to get rid of the
war machines holding it back it's around
this time though that they discovered
that Odin was using the mid Guardians he
say from the Desolation as fodder since
he knew they wouldn't kill them Kratos
has always told atreus to close his
heart to death so that it doesn't affect
him but that's when he realizes he's
wrong that's what the old Kratos would
have done so he instead tells him to
open his heart take in all that grief
and pain because today they will be
better Kratos also decides not to use
Ragnarok and instead use him ether's
flaw this was a tale that was told back
in the last game about how the builder
of the wall left a flaw in the wall for
when Ragnarok starts so that they can
preach Asgard syndriana tries to their
money to fruit who almost kills him but
backs down when she realizes that atreus
is telling the truth and that Odin is
the real villain here she and atreus
will join Kratos and head inside before
being attacked by Thor Thor of course
loses but is spared because Kratos has
changed older Kratos not just Greek
Kratos but even earlier Kratos from the
introduction would have easily killed
him without Mercy but this journey has
changed his outlook on a lot of things
sadly none of that matters as Odin
finishes Thor for him this leads to
willing the boss fight with Odin Odin of
course just like Thor loses but we see
that during their talk atreus ends up
breaking the mask which gets sucked into
the tear and now that and all of its
possible knowledge is gone forever Odin
then loses and gets killed by atreus as
he puts his soul into the ball that was
meant for Kratos this could have
possibly led to a future plot in which
Odin escapes and is set free but's
injury isn't having any of that and just
smashes it to Pieces killing Odin for
good cerder then comes crashing in but
thankfully freyr is able to fend him off
just long enough for the group to escape
on fenrir but fur had to sacrifice
himself in order to do so this is
fascinating to me because in the myth
freyr die ice disorder because he didn't
have his sword but here he dies even
with it fur didn't have his sword
because he left it behind once he
married a woman named gerd because of
that fair at one point had to use an
antler to kill a giant which is the same
weapon he wields when we meet him so
it's a nice nod to both events everyone
except freyr manages to survive and a
trace is woken up by air as atreus we
could talk to some of the survivors and
at the very top are anger Boda and
Kratos anger Boda says that she has
something for the two of them inside
this cave is a panel the real panel the
prophecy we saw on the walls was what
the Giants wanted they wanted Loki to
come and defeat Odin but Faye went
against her own kind she destroyed
atreus's panel in yotenheim so they
didn't know their fate she wanted her
family to make her own choices and shape
Their Own Destiny since atreus's panel
is broken though he is able to make his
own fate and that's when he talks with
Curtis about his plan to find the other
Giants to do this though he will have to
go alone because he believes that he
needs to do this himself Kratos agrees
because of their talk during Ragnarok
and back in helheim and lets his son go
it's sort of like a parent letting their
kid go and live on their own when there
they're a child you could be with them
for as long as you want but now that
they're older they have to live their
own life craters couldn't accept that
because he was worried atreus would get
into trouble or worse when he left and
well to be fair he did release garm go
to Asgard and search for tear all on his
own which didn't really help his case
but Kratos and atreus have changed for
the better and they both recognize that
atreus loves Kratos and all he's done
for him from discipline to training to
just being a father and Kratos is proud
of a trace in the man he's turning into
it's a perfect ending to their once
fractured relationship this however
isn't even the best part as Kratos gets
another look at the panel and finds one
behind it this panel is kratos's and
he's finally done it the panel shows a
golden Kratos being worshiped as a god
it's unclear if it's as the god of war
or just the hero but he's finally being
appreciated and judging by his reaction
this is something he's wanted for ages
also when it's a bit of a stretch but
there's no white in that picture it
could just simply be a stylistic choice
but maybe the ashes will be gone Kratos
May finally get the PC fought tooth and
nail to have Kratos the god killer the
one who killed dozens of odds and
hundreds of creatures for Revenge will
finally be worshiped as a hero he will
no longer be remembered as the ghost of
Sparta murderer and God killer of Greece
but as Kratos the one who saved the nine
Realms and I couldn't have asked for a
better ending to get to this path though
Kratos has lots of work to do which for
the player means finishing up any
content they missed just like in God of
War 2018 there are some secret things we
can find after the game is finished if
you go to nefelheim and take a left
before the Raven tree you can find a
prison cell that has the real tear in it
it's hypothesized that this is where
Odin held those he transformed into this
obviously makes sense since without it
there would have been two tears running
loose and that would have blown his
cover if you go to Alpine we can see
through sitting next to mulnir before
taking off into the sky so it seems like
she'll be wielding the weapon for the
foreseeable future Reddit Oscar will
provide Kratos a more jigsil seeds
meaning more gateways are open like the
one in yotenheim sadly all you can do is
talk to anger Boda and Pat fenrir you
can also visit Charlie again and if you
manage to complete the fave request or
rescue bierger then you can actually
tell him to retire here instead while in
vannheim you can also talk to Sif and
hildizveni who are coming up with plans
on how the Acer and Vayner could coexist
in moves behind you could also challenge
Valkyrie Queen Gana fortunately you
don't have to go through eight other
Valkyries to kill her like Seagram
unfortunately though she's just as tough
as secret after all that though the only
thing left to do is to visit svalterfeim
and partake in Brock's Funeral Derlin
Rabe lunda and syndra are here as well
and they give Brock a viking funeral
it's a sweet and really touching moment
and we can hear Kratos call him friend
Brock's death really did affect him a
lot and it also affects sindri a lot too
wits in its injuries armor is still
stained and when we return to the house
the leaves of the world tree are all
over the floor sinjri is a clean freak
but Brock's death has changed him a lot
he hasn't even taken care of himself yet
hopefully though syndra will be able to
return to his more chip herself over
time once the funeral is given though
the credits Will Roll which signals the
end of God of War Ragnarok as always we
now have to ask what comes next and
honestly I don't know we don't know what
the realm of creation thing was in
Odin's basement and Athena's existence
is still unclear usually we could look
towards a specific scene that teases
some of the future events like God of
War 3's ending but we don't have one in
this game this could honestly be the
final game in the series if I recall
Ragnarok should be the final Norse game
but there are no hints given in this
game that another will happen so who
knows God of War might just end here God
of War could also continue but under
atreus instead of Kratos since his story
is just beginning it's also possible
that they could wrap up atreus's current
journey in a DLC but none of the other
God of War games have ever released DLC
before so I highly doubt Santa Monica
Studios would start now either way
whatever happens we'll just have to wait
and see let me know what you thought
about God of War Ragnarok in the
comments down below and while you're
down there if you have any questions
feel free to comment them and I will try
to clarify any confusion you may have
while you're here just a reminder that I
have a lot of story reviews that you
might be interested in like the one in
the entire God of War series but if you
enjoyed this video then be sure to leave
a like And subscribe as always thank you
to my returning viewers for coming back
to another video and take care everyone
goodbye